[Music]
so nice to see you both thank you thanks
for dressing up i appreciate it
it means i'm comfortable with you it
means thank you that means so much to me
demi let's get started right away what
do you think of simon's tight t-shirts
you know let's talk about this yeah
what's funny is we're we're trying to
reach to a younger demographic yes and i
just don't feel like we're going to
accomplish that when he's showing more
cleavage than brittany and i are yeah
what do you think is this something
you've put a lot of thought into science
didn't show more cleavage yeah i'm good
thank you okay well so am i but i'm not
showing any cleavage this is a t-shirt
i'm surprised cause normally you could
like braid your chest hair
tell her to stop picking on me don't
pick on him he's a kind man who's never
insulted anyone uh
right
you've said it
simon you have said that you find demi
lovato annoying you have said that yes
to to many people you've said that to
the press she's here with you right now
uh let's have at it yeah why would you
say something yeah let's clear it up you
are very annoying thanks
how does that how's that where you are
you could be a bit of an
i know how's that
i'm used to it
you're comfortable being with people
that annoy you yeah i mean let's talk
about seacrest we've got to talk about
seacrest
yeah he was really annoying yeah
he was do you feel at all responsible i
mean you created that man and now he's
become this juggernaut and you let him
loose on america
and it's you unleash him and it's your
fault are you guys still friends you
guys still hang out together uh we talk
occasionally what are you talking about
you were best pals used to get uh
masseuses and we're not together
yes i used to interview the two of you
and you would say you went to spas
together and you get those tables that
face each other to each other having a
massage we may have gone to a spa what's
a massage
[Laughter]
well but you're in this country
[Music]
we fought that one out about 200 years
ago
[Applause]
[Laughter]